hello everyone and welcome to the
laboratory automation and the testing
virtual event my name is Mihai assistant
professor from the university of kansas
and will be presenting on the 3d
microarray technology for empowering the
biomedical research please feel free to
submit questions during my presentation
and I will follow up with you by the
email
so
the three-dimensional micro fluidics and
the way although they have the
three-dimensional micro nano structure
implemented into the micro Sol device so
as the word we're all arranged is
essentially three dimensions so if we
look at all objects present in this
world they all have the height width and
a gap so let's treat dimensional
geometry entries give the big impact to
the surrounding environment
it's also true in a micro scale so
through the micro and the nano
structures come the potential for
engineering the chemical on the boundary
system was the fundamentally new
characteristics and the functionalities
so I want to introduce some new
discovery that we had for this
three-dimensional influence on the
biomedical research
Alyce's start with the fish the
fundamental introduction of the
microarray technology so which is just
device and a technology that can
precisely control and the manipulative
food cells and molecules geometrically
constrain their small network of
channels with dimension from parish to
hundreds of the microns so my clients
very small scale if you look at the
bigger scale that's very typical scale
like ten minutes for a cell or the
molecules to transpose to such 10
million s they will take more than 500
thousand seconds to pass you ten
millimeter which entry equal to vi days
is super long but in a micro scale this
choice purposes can be much faster
clearly in the 10 micron scale for a
cell unlock you'll see transport you may
only take power five seconds to super
fast let's the real situation in the
boundary for system to our small D in
our body the cells and the bra vessels
are in the micro scale service logical
reaction and the event can happen so
quickly to end this micropedic
technology they handle mark yourself in
the micro scale that actually provide a
lot of other marketers like the high
resolution for the single cells in the
molecules the high sensitivity section
of the marker itself and the very high
efficient in terms of mass transfer and
the reciprocal constructions Marlowe
suggests only hand of the micro liter
range of the food and the entire device
let's design a ball called volt and it
is possible
so here I own two like a real
introduction to those three-dimensional
micro for the chips so the processes yes
we all mostly focus on the 2d planar
microarray chip that's the one more
typical standard micro so they plan a
chip show in the middle of the top panel
which is a serpent's channel with a
zigzag planner channel geometry for the
clues mixing and if we design the plane
of micro flick channel into the image
straight dimensional structure as we
show in the top left there also zigzag
structure in the microwave channel
Butler change along the Z dimension so
the trend in the ducts create more
structure and introduce the food to
change in air flow path in the V
direction and then we can notice stir
becomes of simulation Network mixing
process very substantially change
compared to the parlor tricks so if it
is the single straight planet Channel
and as we see from the bottom left there
to whose smooth service comes with
simulations there is no fool mixing
happen at all because in a micro scale
the laminar flow is dominant and the
mixing process the completely depend on
the diffusion process which is slow but
we generate receive dimensional
microstructure which can generate the
local turbulence and a substantially in
help the mixing process so the mixing
can be happen right away in a short time
in three seconds and the width march
efficient compared to the planet chick
was the classic step and each channel as
we show in the middle of the bottom of
simulation we may well compare such big
influence in terms the three dimensional
change of the geometry and the speed
influence on the mixing process so we
divide the primary trip with scheduling
which is a primary settling structure
and the student simulation you can see
the twofold goes through of the y-shaped
Channel and the the to flow century
genomics and all but if we simply curve
this sampling to the knighting degree so
which change the circuit dimension how
generates the local change on a third
dimension with the big dawgs trench
and we also proved the spies the
experimental demonstration just have it
- who dies one is in the blue color
really the one is in the right color so
if we introduce this to close and choose
the printer settling micro so delicious
and the methanol next thing happens and
so as we simulate by the comes of
simulation so the video actually going
to play to show this mixing process
you're going to play the leave you
so as we sit on it exactly
and it's because there's no change on
the third dimension of it back the two
flows me and they still kick the
intersect and one's able to generate and
in turbulence in the microstate channel
so the next thing cannot happen change
that strong time and they don't depend
on the diffusion process
you
so as we demonstrate rubles reading the
geometry and the scale dimension and the
size the fraternal are exactly same but
only in terms just second-rate in the
knighting degrade against to the a
y-shaped introduction channel so there
is a change on the third dimension of
the valve and which actually introduced
a turbulence into the micro channel and
potentially include the mixing process
so which actually do this is an idea the
third dimension of the food control can
be powerful and it can be utilize the
for certain application is passionate in
about medical research let some
application we're going to show later
and on the other advantage of this
three-dimensional geometry just really
important making in various elements of
a system for hits the we know are the
cell culture in the lab our case setting
has show the patter dish the
two-dimensional culture as we
demonstrate at the bottom of the figures
and the cells country has
two-dimensional petri dish and initial
flash if they try to attach to the
bottom and the spread and stretch them
but in the real situation the more
systems cancer tumor cells like we are
showing here may go in the round shape
with a cell overnight each other so if
we stare waste you're folding to
contrast our industries invention may
grow in the morphology of the envelope
like tumor cells as we demonstrate a
lock-up of Muskaan focal image so which
shows up service tumor cells and overlay
each other to form the round shape of
tumor geometry which is the very same
area and level spotted system so which
means this three-dimensional culture
actually contributes to the envelope
system starting in the which can give
small a curative survey of the drug
discovery
thereby matakohe discovery and and we
know the three-dimensional is important
and the powerful but how we can
introduce such a three-dimensional micro
structure into the micro fluidics the
unknown - in traditional manner we have
divided from making a 3d micro fur
device
so here I am showing a coalition of
micro device fabrication which is taken
place in the cleanroom and Nietzsche
Pixlr clean environment is very
expensive facility and one example may
show at bottom the thicker which is the
grass based in microfluidic chip made in
the criminal and less of a cheaper
solution give the PDMS polymer material
to make some micro Sadiq chip so I saw
the molding of the PDMS you'll need to
use the UV source of the philosophy
which is the very expensive equipment
set up in the claim of 2 and now allow
the developments of the 3d printing
technology we actually can use the 3d
printer to fabricate in micro state
shape so listen to one example we on the
bottom of the right hand which is a very
spend our microwaves is a mixing channel
my print buys the 3d printer
and a 3d printer integrate all the
fabrication part of those changes one
step and they you can simply convert a
digital file into the 3d printing
software and then for the one button
touch and then 3d printer actually can
share with the device so this layer by
layer crazy to form the micro stitches
and the witnesses bench talks unit which
is a customer's way 3d printer and then
we can print the most two motive PDMS
polymer and also we can direct the print
maker for the channel for the direct
printing we have the not supposed to be
printers in our lab and the one we use
it LCL a baseless 3d printer which can
produce to a printing revolution at
around 30 micron scale and the printer
micro through a channel and wear well
and we also have the the high research
grade 3d printer from the emission tag
and that which can print the premium s
polymer material and we also can use a
3d printer to generate the modes which
can motor PDMS into a small breaks with
the different three-dimensional micro
structures and reassemble them to form
the more complicated three-dimensional
channel work network so this is one
example which is a 3d printer to print
microfilm mixing trip and also we can
directly print the circle well and as
you see from the top kind of the image
and then there is a couple well in the
middle and also this microstate mixture
can introduce the flows into the micro 3
channel for faster mixing sugar capital
for streaming and in the printing
performance and our program ocean or
catalyzed by the SEM image show on the
bottom of the panel figures and they
will put out different type of
structures include the post array and
micro well and hollow Channel and
initial pretty good shape and also very
smooth surface and in the prison you are
motion to form the whole channel is
around 100 microns
and we also have some molding process so
we use this 3d printer to print the moat
and even use some room to molded PDMS
polymers so as we show in the figure we
can move all different types of the
macrophylla channels and to levitate the
PDMS trip from the mode and reusable for
many times and then attachment PMS
linear was a micro Filipino to regard
life to home the microvilli chip it's
very simple and with low cost and we
also characterized the modern precision
so we comparator can always do the most
and also to see how my comparable with
molded PDMS so basically through the
channel dimension around 50 microns to
500 micron so Lincoln trafficking level
well with a good reproducibility so with
such three-dimensional micro fabrication
skills and then we want to utilize this
our school to a once over medical
research the first application were in
car in the market detection so as we
know there by masses circulating in the
bloodstream and if we can detect certain
protein which is a biomarker indicating
the various phases from the single drop
of blood I can make them of that non-sex
much easier and a trooper so let's
define markers can provide less invasive
more precise diagnosis of colon ulcers
and the prediction so the one
application we applied in anemia you'll
see the point-of-care Diagnostics so we
know the hemoglobin which is a protein
less
indications of the anemia
if lover of the hemoglobin in the
bathroom is rather low then let's copy
religious anemia in there some kind of
care devices available on the market for
detecting the hammelburg
vocal from the single dropping abroad
and the parrot device always need a
power supply and now possible so if a
little relative expensive compared to
the low resource settings country of
silver country
then we introduce the studio printing
technology and to fabricate the micro
for the chips and this is a customer
base 2d printer to generate the
microchips for a given reclaim about it
serving a dinner requires more expensive
facility to manufacturers microchips and
also intended a 3d printer to help make
it the case that hands pictures of cell
phone camera to host the muscle to the
chicks from the color scale detection so
this result can be recorded by the cell
phone and I Mars the beta and
essentially the hospital and the
hospital actually can get connected with
doctor so I reduce the rivet to the
hospital dispassionately useful from the
ruler area they don't have much access
over transportation to the clinical
village
so the calculator for scaling is very
important in this development this we
want to reduce the power usage and if we
can treat the surface of this 3d
printing microfilmed mixer and choose
the very hydrophilic property and the
list actually can introduce the flow
into the micro three channel
automatically through the capillary for
screaming tsunamis we don't need any
power supply to drive the flow and we
divert the surface of the 3d printing
your micro three Channel and the is the
selling hydrophilic company to treat the
surface and then we can see the correct
angle country change and it's the last
contact endo actually have much more
power to introduce the flow based on a
temporary horse as we show in this
figure and we started a different flow
piece as the wetlands allowing the
different contact angle
so we can treat those to do punting
microchannel on to super high your
Zurich where the comp a tender allows 32
bigness it can drive the floor quickly
into the microphone channel and the most
treatments that you can be simply
realize them by introduced distortion to
go through the firing reaction and the
SVC
before the treatment and after treatment
the surface properly actually changed to
the FDR environment on the right and of
the figure and we can see this to be
resin after treatment show the very
hydrophilic properties with the contact
angle allow 30 to have the much more
power to try to flow into the microscope
channel and you live well we different
reagents which can introduce the redox
reaction with the single blood drop and
undergo the reduction reaction to
produce
to produce this ocean of age the color
of this place
so we characterize this color still this
price and the worth of concentration
of the hem Ogami so as we see from this
calibration curve and allow the change
of the colors
under the concentration of the hello
building Audrey change with which is a
linear response and a quantitative Lee
give the concentration of the hello B so
if we recall the color of the curve
actually and after mixing and the we can
convert this color into the exact
digital concentration of the hemoglobin
and again the indication of the anemia
serious like in the red color the help
of the concentration means the healthy
speakers and the ASA makes incorrect
turn into the blue now it's very low
concentration of the Hamill domain and
the which enter indicates anemia status
so we the Restless point of care
Diagnostics keep the service industry be
printing of the micropedic chip and the
for detecting the hemoglobin from the
finger prick blood the mixing process is
very fast with a 16 second in the some
code and the overall construction is
very low it's possible and transferable
and we also compare our rewind right
measured hmmm in concentration with the
clinic environment using a helmet audio
analyzer so show the quantity in the
subjects in the lake and see the moment
quite comparable and is a correlation
with clinical measurement is over nine
increased 19% and it will also test to
the stress of the city and the
responsibility of this communal test our
our DM to the 3d printing basis plc
detection of the anemia and there we can
see the specificity
through our device there's no small
phones POC detection actually showed
pretty good for the severe anemia
detection dispense with the city
coverage to the 100 percent for the zoom
out anemia
depression actually the sensitivity rich
um 100% so overall loose technology
actually
to use the low cost of POC diagnosis
strategy for anemia and also follow
Jesus self management which can formula
in one process as the center also so and
this is the comparables an outpatient
facility specifically with a standard
clean for hama collagen analyzer
the other one example answers shows
through the street in printing
technology I tree can introduce the new
geometry for realizing the more
complicated micro structure so we can
use the 3d printer to generate the mode
and the mode actually these two motor
pls and the the PDMS is a small brake
rotor firmness mode which we can use as
the Lego just like you play Lego and
then you can reassemble this Lego bricks
and into the more complex structure
which has we will now be able to point
to you by the 3d printer so this is the
one demonstration we have the for PDMS
motor brakes and to assemble from
three-dimensional micro to the in actual
transaction system and as we show at
bottom of this figure in African tenders
multiple three-dimensional channel
network provides central confucian
process or culture three-dimensional
cells
and if you must molding process you can
generate small complexes two-dimensional
channel network as what your notes
traded in the top panel of figures and
the figure D actually is molded PDMS
breaks and you can have four pieces of
this brick and the to establish killer
from the three-dimensional circuit
resistance and this electric creation
cartridge was coordinated by a 3d
printer as well at which can use to
control the natural field through the
three dimensional gaming and it to
perform the transaction
and the 3d cell culture actually can we
perform in this device and also have a
much better performance in terms of your
3d cell growth 2's way see on the right
hand on the left hand the figure 8 shows
the distribution of the 3d culture cell
with the staining of the nucleus and as
you can see the cell actually
distributed in the three-dimensional
culture environment in this device and
the sound girl in the three-dimensional
morphology more like the liver tumor
shape and we also characterize the
stricken culture cells by using the SEM
and TEM
with the CSL girl just like a memo to
myself with lyrical attachment and
interaction with extracellular matrix
and the straight dimensional arrangement
of maternal network as we illustrated by
Wisconsin simulation provide better
performance of the punctuation and which
can provide work efficiently and help
supply of the nutrients and waste
exchange and asana mail exchange which
allows the cell to grow much better so
as we sit in the finger space with our
industry lean micro selected
construction system with
three-dimensional chess channel network
and a distinction from talked and
concealed in channel and send so much
moisture and unlock the subscription
happen work quickly in the seconds
much better than conventional workplace
subconscious system
in the moolah we'll introduce this
multi-directional electrical scanning
process and which provide very uniform
electric field distribution industry
dimensional way and we can see now
enable the plasma to crisp or into the
cell in a much efficient flick and as we
concur and volume of the handle figures
if we only use a one-dimensional
standing of the electric field and there
were few of those 3d cells can be
constructed but if we introduce in a
trestle still all dimensional in the top
bottom left right keep rotating between
the scanning and switch conserve as much
precision transfection
to introduce the polymer into a $30 so
I'm going to play the video and the
illness right 25 which shows operation
of this multi-directional electric field
scanning okay please pray the radio
you
all right so you can say the scallion
Chris - because we are swrus a location
between autumn images so which can
introduce the constantly for extraction
much more efficiently and meanwhile kick
the gue cell viability so here we
started a different condition of this
electrical scanning include the wattage
the power generation and beauty cycle
and also the concentration of the
positive now we can apply and we can see
the transaction rate is 2 more than 15%
a certain voltage and also men want to
keep the GU sound liability above the
80% so the pathway concentrations of my
entity primary are here that if we keep
the high concentration of plasma and as
a transaction rate always granted by
high in a meanwhile cuticles now
liability so might allow us to optimize
those transaction process with the
Predators to control the best efficient
transaction and we also utilize this
transcription process to introduce the
current flow licensed public enforcement
into the survey cancer to myself and the
witch culture and three-dimensional
culture custom in our device so we can
see the personally it was introduced
into the 3d cells and the which active
role in the grand fluorescence which can
be measured by the flow cytometry
so sure this measurement we can coat the
cell I can be corrected the end until
calculates the cell transformation
equation 6 and authors del Y delegates
analytics really useful especially for
the tissue engineering because the cells
need to be transported with the certain
pathway to write the layer usual
function and the one application we
enter import to deliver the crisp
location I plasmid into the hack cells
and as we see the culture to excel in
the 3d entry girl like a long strip
like in Liverpool marshes and we can
introduce the crisper case knife until
the city culture heck cells which can
just factor into the cells to show that
when fluorescence contract and we also
stay in the nucleus with the show in the
figure one F which is a computer image
and the can come the cell numbers with
Illustrated cut yourself clusters so we
can see how many three because your
cells was transected by the CRISPR case
knife pathway and we can know the
transferring efficiency as we see from
the figure Z which the one single cells
and at respective worthless Chris
rotation AIGFP and the ones with self
divided into two daughter cells actually
passed they're going for a reference
property internet dot itself
that means we're affected creates
birthday psy trance function
syllabus two examples shows the good
application just reading microfluidics
and we dentistry smash 3d printing we
able to microfabrication
of the microsil device with the
three-dimensional micro structure that
includes of us printing and it's tricky
molding of the PDMS micro fleece chip
and also you can use a straight in micro
assembly to create the more complicated
network and as a fabrication process is
simple fast and a low cost and
hopelessly the micro structures
implemented into the micro device
absolutely the control of the value
system for advancing the by my own
research our and in and once you give
acknowledgement to my collaborators from
the key you and if you can suspend
regiment a hospital and our space and
also understand the funding support and
also my group members from for Costa and
for graduate students here alright thank
you very much for your time